hi there welcome to another episode of
science and technology q a for kids and
others
so i'm happy to try and answer
all kinds of questions people might ask
about science how things work technology
how things work
uh at all levels but particularly
ones
that uh
are kind of things people have wondered
about
and uh
just uh curious about how things might
work
all right let's see we have a few left
over here from previous times there's
one from rookie
what technological and or scientific
capabilities must humans achieve to be
able to manipulate and reprogram mata at
will
okay it's an interesting question
so
let's see
mata
is you know made of atoms they're bound
together they make solids things like
that
well let me say first of all
mata tends to come in solids liquids and
gases those are the three standard
phases of matter it doesn't cover
typical biological systems which are
usually gels that are sort of a little
bit solid a little bit liquid and so on
doesn't cover things like fire that's a
plasma but your average material comes
as either solid liquid or gas that's
like water is is
you know ice many different kinds of ice
liquid water just one kind of liquid
water or so it seems and steam just one
kind of steam
and
the when you talk about reprogramming
matter the typical thing you might be
thinking about is solids because solids
are things that sort of stay the way
they are liquids flow and change their
configuration gases they're always
moving around all the time so we're
really talking about solid objects
and so the question is if you're going
to
uh sort of re you're going to define how
a solid is configured well you have to
make sure that the atoms that you put in
the places where you put them are going
to stay where you put them
it's no good to have something where you
built this giant sort of city of of
molecules or or atoms placed in
different places and it just all
collapses that doesn't work but there
are processes like for example atomic
force microscopes can pick up single
atoms and just place them on a solid
surface and you can do that to some
extent with some kinds of atoms
to a certain degree if you try and sort
of build it up too much it will it will
start collapsing and it will just sort
of for the
collapse of its own atoms will get
attracted to each other repelled from
each other and they'll just sort of
rearrange themselves
there's a there's a kind of a well-known
uh lure of force law between atoms
often um um
uh the leonard jones potential is the
most common thing people use and it says
if you take two atoms two atoms that
don't have electric charges and you kind
of move them but if you move them really
close to each other they'll repel if
they're a bit further apart they'll
attract so people often think about the
inverse square law
which is what governs
for example electrical interactions that
means that if two things are a distance
r apart the um uh the the the force
between them is is goes like one over r
squared
um in the case of just neutral atoms the
length jones potential it's like one of
our art of the sixth
is the is the force of attraction so it
kind of dies off very quickly as you as
you move the atoms apart the one over r
to the twelfth is the force of repulsion
when the things get really close
together so that's kind of the thing
that you're you're dealing with whenever
you're kind of arranging atoms is
they'll have some force law that governs
how they'll be how they'll be connected
to each other and so on so you can you
can but you can to some extent you can
just sort of pick them up with some kind
of um
uh pick up
individual atoms and arrange them what
you want and people have done kind of
cute things where they write logos
within
individual atoms and so on so that's a
that's kind of a thing you can do to
kind of shape something now if you say
reprogram matter well most matter
doesn't do stuff
most matter like solid objects just sit
there
being solid objects and don't change
their configuration the kinds of things
that uh it is it is the rare kind of
matter that can kind of change its
configuration and in fact even in in
biological systems where we have
examples of molecules that really do
things so to speak you know we have
molecules where i don't know you can
have
one molecule that kind of walks along
the the strand of another molecule we
can have a molecule that
has some particular um that when it's
when there's some electrical effect the
like our actin molecules in our muscles
when there's an electrical uh uh
um
when there's a
voltage there that the molecule will
contract
um will so there are things like that
where a molecule will like do stuff
now i suppose you could ask the question
could you make a molecule that will
just
kind of where you could program it to do
whatever you want how would you give an
input maybe you give it an electrical
voltage maybe you shine light on it um
maybe maybe other molecules come and
interact with it
by the time you're dealing with other
molecules interacting with it you're
dealing more with chemical reactions
you're dealing less with configuring
matter like a solid object you're more
dealing with something like a liquid
where you know chemical reactions can
happen much more readily in the liquid
because molecules are all
always running into each other that's
sort of the the best case for chemical
reactions is a liquid because the
molecules are still all moving around
and the different things that might
react with each other will eventually
find each other in the liquid yet there
are lots of molecules there so it's not
like a gas where it's quite dilute and
the molecules might just never find each
other and it's not like a solid where
the molecules just locked in place and
will never interact with each other
that's kind of why you know in the in uh
um in in airports it's like you can't
take too many liquids on planes because
that's where you could make chemical
reactions and make uh you know
explosives and who knows what else um
whereas that's that's not something with
a solid you don't get to have chemical
reactions happen because the molecules
are locked in place
in um uh in a um
in the kind of uh crystal structure or
whatever else it is in in the solid
so it's usually either a crystal where
the molecules arrange a very regular
array or something like an amorphous
solid like a glass where the molecules
are just like it's just like throwing
balls into a ball pit they're just all
the sort of atoms are just sort of uh
arranged randomly like that
but in any case there's there's sort of
a different question
of whether you can set up molecules so
that a molecule itself or a piece of
material as soon as something happens to
it as soon as some atom array arrives at
one end suddenly you've got this uh you
know giant with this microscopic kind of
cog-based thing where sort of an atom
will move and another atom will move and
eventually you'll get
something that behaves like let's say a
mechanical
computer can you make things like that
out of atoms well people were very
interested in that about um oh we're now
30 30 to 40 years ago
um
and uh the whole sort of early idea of
molecular machines and now early
versions of nanotechnology and so on
there was a big effort to try and think
about how would you actually make kind
of machine-like things but down at the
molecular scale and and it seems to be
perfectly plausibly possible the problem
is it's it's hard to get that sort of
manufacturing device
to to start i mentioned that you can
move individual atoms into place but
it's a really slow process and if you
wanted to build a thing of non-trivial
size it would take ridiculously long
doing that it probably wouldn't even be
successful it would it would kind of
deform as a result of those atomic
forces and so on but so the the thing
that people have always hoped for is
that you will be able to make a
molecular assembler that where you've
successfully done this process of sort
of going and making a um a thing that
can move
move the atoms around an atomic an
atomic scale and you do it just once and
you make an atomic molecular assembler
and then the mercury assembler can make
a production line and making other
molecular assemblers and pretty soon you
have molecular assemblers all over the
place and then you can start saying you
know have this little tiny arm that's
made of a few atoms and so on move this
around and do this and that and the
other
um one of the things that happened when
that was being discussed like 35 or so
years ago was people got very worried
well if you could start making molecular
assemblers like that maybe you would
start being able to just turn all the
matter in the world
into i think it was usually called gray
goo
where sort of the molecular assembler
would be very successfully taking atoms
from everything and just turning them
into some boring goo type thing
now in a sense
biological life
is doing something a little bit like
that you know when when you have
a
uh you know it's taking materials
nutrients whatever from the soil the
atmosphere whatever else and it's
turning those things into the goo
of i don't know some some uh
piece of algae or
some fungus or something like this
and uh that hasn't you know hasn't ended
the world to do that the concern was if
you make molecular assembly really work
and it becomes really efficient you can
kind of just like start taking over the
world and the whole thing turns into
this gray goo
and sort of everything in the world just
turns to that and that's really bad and
i think that's that's one of the several
reasons why kind of the the
nanotechnology this molecular assembly
thing sort of people
well there were a number of different
reasons that had to do with sort of
details of of uh oh i don't know people
in chemistry and materials science
saying oh there's this new thing we
don't really like that and just a whole
lot of of weird kind of scientific
politics and so on
but
it doesn't sort of change the the
question of
what uh
well you know this whole question about
programmable matter
um
the uh
gosh
um many different ways to take this and
maybe i shouldn't spend too much too
much more time on it but but um
uh
a bunch of
things i've worked on
with cellular automata for example these
very simple
uh
very simple rules where you just have a
collection of cells and each cell is
updated depending on the the colors of
its neighbors you could imagine
implementing a cellular automaton in at
an atomic scale if you could do that
and if you could specify the initial
values of this collection of cells
then it's rather easy to make cellular
automata that can act like arbitrary
computers and that means that you can
readily sort of do a computation at the
molecular scale i kind of suspect there
may be easier ways to do computations
than molecular scale that don't even
just work in that don't require kind of
solid phase type stuff but that's a
that's a somewhat different story um i
think that there's also
an interesting direction um not so much
as kind of solid phase make an arbitrary
piece of matter um is uh the level of
things like drugs where most drug
molecules
work by there's some molecule that is
important in in our biology and it has a
certain shape and a drug molecule comes
in and it has a certain shape too and
its shape kind of locks into some active
site on the molecule that it's trying to
affect that is part of us so to speak
and so the molecule will come in and it
will be a a blocking of the function of
the molecule that's in us or an
enhancing of the function of the
molecule that's in us and so on but most
drug molecules work by the sort of
physical structure of just can you fit
into this pocket in this other molecule
and so on so one of the things that i've
long thought would be the case is that
eventually one can imagine molecules
that are sort of algorithmic drug
molecules where in addition to just
saying do i fit into this little pocket
here the thing has essentially sensors
on the molecule that are part of the
molecule that can be sensitive to other
features of the environment and say well
i'm only going to block this molecule if
the following six other things are true
and that's a way to get much more
specific in being able to attack or or
help some some particular piece of of
biological tissue
but um there's there's there's yeah
there's there's more to say this i i
think about this i think but i think
that the idea
of for example let me just make a thing
okay so so here's a question can you
have a 3d printer that prints a
molecular scale
so it's an interesting question
3d printers that print
at a microscopic scale that have you
know plastic or metal or sugar or
whatever they're printing with
one of the things that's notable about
3d printers is they're not quite as easy
to set up as you might have thought
because when you print it matters that
you can't for example end up printing
something that's just in mid-air and has
no supports there's a certain uh sort of
design for printability that's necessary
and every printer has different
constraints about you know where its
print head can go and and what can hold
up what and and how does heat get
dissipated as the print head uh extrudes
another piece of plastic all those kinds
of things so i think one can expect that
when one is doing uh kind of molecular
scale things there will be at least all
those constraints and perhaps many more
and uh you know i think that's but i
think the the hope would be that
eventually one can make a molecular
assembler that can make other molecular
assemblers that's that's kind of the the
desire and then you'd be able to sort of
make any structure of a molecule
in terms of okay for example one
question is could you make a mechanical
computer at molecular scale this was
something people talked about like 40
years ago or something and and the
answer is it's not physically impossible
it's just hard to make it
and you know even if you look at
bacteria for example they have flagella
that are that are kind of um uh sort of
um
uh sort of tails
that are attached to the um to the the
bacterium and if you look with an
electron microscope or something you'll
see that they actually have little gear
teeth they're little cogs and they move
around they're kind of like motors that
move step by step by step and they look
very much like kind of little machines
and so that's a place where that's just
made of protein molecules
that's a place where one's able to make
something that kind of looks like a
piece of a mechanical computer
um and that's uh you know another
approach that people have tried to take
is to use dna
which is a molecule where where one can
sort of specify the sequence um on the
molecule and and it curls up differently
depending on what that sequence is and
so on to use dna as the kind of raw
material to make uh to make arbitrary
things out of so not dna as a way that
happens in us where it's a thing for
programming cells where you make from
dna you you know through rna and so on
you make proteins um but rather to use
dna as an actual kind of building block
itself where for example you might make
a tile where there's an edge to the tile
that's a sequence that's a dna sequence
and it can only be attached to another
tile that has the appropriate
complementary dna sequence and so on and
so you can start kind of building up um
the uh
building up a structure just by using
dna itself and dna is a fairly stable
molecule unlike rna um and so that
that's a that's a possible thing to do
i've always thought that it's a little
bit of a an unfortunate kind of
admission of of technology defeat to say
we don't know how to make something
which outer molecules ourselves let's
just
uh leverage uh kind of what biology has
done it's kind of like um we don't know
how to make a bicycle instead we're
going to ride a horse because horses
already exist and they'd be made by
biology and i kind of think it would be
nice if one could do it so from first
principles without having the whole uh
you know whole giant bag of chemistry
associated with specifically with dna
all right let's see
um
okay questions here about can i explain
crispr um
from aaron and slayer
so
basic issue is
if
uh crispr is a technique for gene
editing it's a technique for changing
dna changing dna
by just saying i want to change the dna
so you know we humans have
dna strands that have about 6 billion
base pairs in them
what that means is there's a little
block of atoms that is a base sometimes
called a residue in um
that is
some particular block of atoms and there
are four different kinds of blocks of
atoms a c t g
um
and you can ask me what those stand for
and i'm always uh
i always forget guanine and i don't know
ac gt
and um the the way
and there's a
there's a backbone to dna which forms
this kind of double helix structure and
then there are these uh bases that go on
that backbone and so every thing about
us
that is specified genetically is
programmed in our dna
in that sequence of acgt and so on and
dna is usually it's it's a double
stranded thing and when when cells
divide they replicate their dna by the
two strands zipping apart and and then
and then uh the the the then them
becoming double stranded again by just
picking up um picking up mole atoms that
they can sort of fill their
complementary pieces with but the basic
point is the dna molecule is this long
string where it has some sequence of
acgt and so on and the way the chemistry
works out and this is kind of a
cleverness of biology is you can have
any sequence of acgt and so on it
doesn't any sequence will work the it's
not the case that the molecule will only
hang together if there's a particular
sequence any sequence will work
so then the question is well what
sequence do you get and normally that's
determined just by
uh genetics of um you know you start
from
your um
the um
uh
um
uh you start from um uh the um
uh
you know your your parents dna and then
you get a copy of that dna and so on
um
and yeah you can tell that i'm more of a
a computational person than a person who
has been in labs making things in
biology and someone just put
on here the list okay so it's adenosine
thymine cytosine and guanine and i guess
i i have very much heard of all of those
i i'm now i should commit that to memory
so the next time this comes up i'm i'm
not um uh
i'm i'm not gonna say just acgt
um
anyway
the um
so
uh
that's dna can be this arbitrary
sequence now the question is if you want
to go and edit that dna to what extent
can you just sort of arbitrarily
determine i want my dna to have uh to i
want to replace this sequence in the dna
with some other sequence
well how would you do that
well
what happened is that in the last i know
when was it
10 years ago 15 years ago rather
recently
a whole chain of different little
discoveries were made about
bacteriophages viruses and infect
bacteria and this little mechanism and
that little mechanism and eventually
there was this
sort of collection of mechanisms that
got called crispr cas9 that are
basically a way of saying
here's
here's a new sequence that i want to
insert at this position in dna
go insert it
and there have been
um
the the question of
of uh how do you normally get sort of
different dna sequences well you can you
can create a sequence sort of step by
step with a with a machine that just
actually sort of
knits together a dna strand you know
base pair by base pair um you can do
things where you take uh sort of
sequences that exist from other
organisms and you kind of graft them
into things and so on but the idea of
just being able to you specify a
sequence you specify where it should go
and then it inserts itself that's kind
of the the thing of gene editing and and
the crispr idea so how does it figure
out where to insert itself the answer is
the what it does is it says what are the
flanking sequences what are the the the
the sequences on your dna and because of
the combinatorics of dna you don't need
a very long sequence to know
that for it to be the case that that's
the only place that occurs so for
example for human dna i don't know what
it is that's c6 base pair seven base
pair something like that
that's
not always enough there are some
sequences that repeat a lot and those
always cause trouble for for um
for gene sequencing and so on because
the way that works but but usually by
the time you have a decently long
sequence i don't know 12 15 base pairs
that kind of thing the chance that will
only occur at most once on human genome
so if you have a some process where it
says only do something at a place where
um
uh whether these particular flanking
sequences the thing will just sort of
float around and eventually it will find
that place on the dna where the flanking
sequences match and let's say okay let
me go and snip the dna reinsert this new
sequence there and now you've changed
your dna
so that's a big deal because if you for
example let's say that you have a
particular
version of a particular gene that is
liable to give you cancer or that or
that produces some
uh some
some enzyme or something that is very
bad for you
or that has
some other or that isn't able to produce
something that you need for some kind of
cell you can say well let's just go in
and edit it
and and that's kind of the idea and
there's been a small number of of trials
of of therapies that are based on that
i'm sure there'll be a lot more in time
to come as is always the case with
medicine all sorts of crazy things go
wrong
you you know you you try and do
something for that relates to i don't
know uh degeneration of the retina of
the eye
and you're you know injecting some uh
something that contains this you know
crispr cast 9 thing and then then that
makes a change that wasn't the one you
expected and has a side effect here
because the flanking sequence was was uh
bound to some other part of the dna it's
always there's always some complexity to
what happens
um and um the uh
the thing that um
uh so so you know that's that's one
story of crispr now there are some other
things
that um like one of the uh
you know you can you can potentially
one one feature of of actually editing
the dna of an organism
is then it will pass it on to all of its
progeny so by the time your dna is
edited if you edit it if if the dna of a
of a of a cell that um uh is is going to
keep replicating and so on is edited in
you then all the things that come from
that cell are also edited so people have
all kinds of schemes of of changing the
mosquito population by having um uh by
sort of driving uh a change in their
genetics into into that population and
so on and there are all kinds of
terrible things that could go wrong type
situations
um but the the um uh that's that's kind
of the the
the basic idea of um of gene editing and
and sort of the notion is can you make a
sort of computer-aided design system
where you just basically say hey i want
to change my dna in this way and you can
go and just start changing it the actual
design process is not quite so simple
because there are all kinds of design
constraints on where exactly you can do
this insertion and there's gradual
development of the sort of technology of
exactly what are the um you know what
are the sort of supports you need and
the a little bit like the 3d printing
thing of what exactly do you need to
have to be able to insert that that
sequence and so on um but that's the
basic idea
um
let's see
uh
the question here from aaron
why are routines for sleeping eating
exercise so helpful for mammals when is
routine harmful
you know
one of the things that i don't think we
understand terribly well
is that
our bodies
have a definite rhythm to them
uh part of it is the circadian rhythm
the rhythm that is uh connected to
the uh the the daily rhythm you know we
are we are set up to
uh sort of be this way at this time of
day and that way at that time of day to
fall sleepy at this time of day be
really energetic at that time of day uh
you know produce secrete this hormone at
that time of day those kinds of things
and part of that
is mediated in our brain by the
pituitary gland and things like that in
the center of our brain
but it's there's there's good evidence
that in every single cell of our body
there is some amount of circadian rhythm
that develops there are some
some sequences of genes and gene
activation that basically pick up this
rhythm this sort of 24 hour rhythm and
it gets synchronized presumably by
things like light and by you know are
you in sunlight or you're not in
sunlight those kinds of things but it's
something which once once it's got that
rhythm
it will tend to just keep going with
that rhythm until it's sort of forcibly
re
uh resynchronized and you know when you
go to different time zones and you get
jet lag and things like that the story
of that is that you're you're sort of uh
you're uh you're disrupting those
circadian rhythms and it can take weeks
even a month
even longer for the sort of circadian
rhythm of all the different parts of
your body effectively to adapt to this
new different time zone and you know it
was thought originally that it was just
a feature of the brain and um but it
seems not to be it seems to be something
sort of in all our different cells and
so it's really a a
thing where our for whatever reason um
it is sort of a a feature of uh of
biology that
biology likes to keep itself organized i
suppose in that way and to have
organisms kind of do things at
repeatable times now now presumably that
was of adaptive advantage back in the
day when it's like don't go out at night
where you're when your you know night
vision predator is going to eat you
don't um you know uh don't uh bake in
the sun at midday um you know try to
collect your food in the morning or
something before it gets too hot in the
desert or whatever else and so it
probably was useful to have a calendar
so to speak for for organisms and that's
um no doubt in sort of the evolutionary
way of explaining things that's kind of
um how that type of thing developed and
i think
the um
generally uh
for for us humans
uh people do better when they have a
definite schedule and it's always quite
disruptive when people have to kind of
jump around to different schedules
people people sometimes uh the the
eventually the schedule tends to be
synchronized to things like the sun most
people have a natural schedule it isn't
quite 24 hours for example and and
people will have you know experiments
but people have done where you're you
know in a cave without any outside light
and you don't know what time it is and
you don't have a watch and and so on and
it must be difficult to do those
experiments now with computers where
there's just an awful lot of places to
get the time so to speak but anyway in
any case the um uh but people tend to
have um a little bit less than i think
it's more common to have a less than 24
hour schedule than a more than 24 hour
schedule and people who are like in uh
you know hard working on this or that
thing have a habit
of of letting their schedules you know
some people and
who are um will sort of let their
schedules drift and they'll they'll
sometimes drift by by you know being oh
it's 24 hours and 30 minutes
each day between when they when they the
successive times they get up so their
schedules will kind of gradually shift
around the day
but um i i think it's um
uh you know the thing that's surprising
about circadian rhythms is that so many
things getting trained in it not only
when you feel sleepy but also what is
your body temperature uh you know when
do you feel hungry
what um uh other kinds of secretion from
from glands
that um you know happen at different
times of day and so on i mean it's just
like like biology has this habit once
you've got some particular train you're
going on just pile all these things onto
that train like you've got the sleep
wakefulness cycle okay let's throw all
these things into what happens when
you're asleep let's throw these things
into these particular times when you you
know wake up or whatever else so i think
that's um uh that's that's the kind of
way that that works
um
there's a question here from mikhail is
there an example where self-assembly is
industrially used
so the level of molecules self-assembly
is used quite a lot i mean you know your
average virus uses it to assemble the
capsid of the virus
it's pieces of protein or some molecules
like insulin i think is a is a molecule
that comes originally in in five
different pieces and they they assemble
themselves so at the molecular scale
there are definitely examples well
they're really biological examples uh
where self-assembly is used um in terms
of
uh assembling things things which
assemble themselves i mean i am i'm
having a hard time thinking of that i
mean i i could imagine a case
where you have a mechanical object which
can only be fit together in a certain
way and you just sort of jiggle things
around and eventually it fits together
and that's sort of a version of
self-assembly but i don't think i mean
usually there has to be some process
that's doing the assembling even if it's
just jiggling things around but i'm not
sure
i can't immediately think of let me see
um
no i mean there are plenty of things
that are sort of chemical which you can
think of as self-assembly like you put
two chemicals together and they have a
reaction where these two molecules were
put together in a certain way and you
can think of that as a sort of
self-assembly process um i think at a
slightly larger scale you can imagine i
don't know you're making some kind of
concrete and it has particles of
different sizes and you kind of smoosh
the things together and they end up
getting um uh and they end up the the
small particles go between the big
particles in a certain fashion and
that's kind of a self-assembly type of
thing but in terms of in terms of
something as impressive as some of the
molecular self-assembly where things
sort of fit together in this nice
icosahedral shape or something because
the molecules just fit in the right way
i'm i'm not immediately coming up with
an example of that
um
that's it's a question also from mikhail
how harmful are plane flights in terms
of radiation exposure
um so what what you know
where does radiation come from
uh in
there's a bunch of radiation so
radiation
is the result of atomic nuclei
self-destructing and producing uh
particles that are going fast maybe
they're electrons maybe they're photons
maybe they're alpha particles which are
like helium nuclei
and there are a variety of ways that
that radiation can be produced one of
them that's pretty common is radon which
is a a
a gas that's radioactive that
can seep up from the ground in different
places and people in different parts of
the world and different uh kind of
settings people are always concerned
about that in in when you build
buildings it's like you know doing radon
inspections and things so one source of
radioactivity can be uh from from
reactivity in in the ground um that's
that's one source another source of
radioactivity is from cosmic rays um
from uh
radiation that comes from mostly from
the sun
um although there are cosmic rays that
come long distances away from from uh
energetic stars and other processes even
outside our galaxy but um uh the most
most cosmic rays are coming from the sun
and
that there's sort of a stream of
particles just as the sun produces light
it also produces streams of charged
particles like mostly protons and so on
um and those uh hit the atmosphere of
the earth and they um
uh they go a certain distance by sea
level mostly gone the only thing most of
the primary protons from the cosmic rays
that hit the the top atmosphere of the
earth
they're all they're all dissipated by
the what they've crashed into other
protons they've they've made a cascade
of particles there are some muons the
neutrinos which just go right through
the earth actually but but there are
muons that survive at the earth's
surface and there's probably a muon goes
through us at sea level
maybe once every couple of minutes
um just one muon doesn't really do any
harm
uh if you go to higher altitudes there's
less atmosphere for the protons to have
interacted in and so there are more
primary cosmic ray protons and even if
you go to you know denver which is a
mile high
there will be significantly more i would
guess
five times more i'm not sure maybe more
than that i could work it out um let's
see i vaguely remember
oh let's see we can calculate it
the atmosphere is the equivalent of 33
feet of water right is there's the
pressure
um and or or 760 millimeters of mercury
um
those are the atmospheric pressure and
that tells us something about the amount
of material in sort of a column above us
in the atmosphere and then you can work
out
boy this is a this is a bit of a
complicated calculation the the uh the
protons to interact the the interaction
cross-section
at um small energies is about 40
millibars um and uh well i i don't know
whether i can do this in my head um
could with a little bit more effort um
can probably work out what the what the
amount of i mean there will be
there'll be gradually more and more
primary cosmic ray protons so by the
time you're at 40 000 feet which is the
altitude that commercial planes tend to
fly at or 36 40 000 feet whatever
there is significantly more cosmic
radiation
um how much of it gets uh i think some
of it is absorbed in the aluminum skin
of the plane but but plenty of it is
still still going so to speak is it a
significant effect no it's not a very
significant effect um is it something
that is the equivalent of i think you
know when you when you get an x-ray for
your teeth or some other thing you get a
certain amount of radiation it's the
amount of radiation has been going down
because x-ray digital x-ray
sensors are much more sensitive than
x-ray film and so on tended to be and so
you need many fewer uh many fewer x-rays
and and lower energy x-rays to get the
same kind of images um but i think that
the uh you know flying around the world
all the time at 40 000 feet is the
equivalent of a modest number of
of teeth x-rays and things so it's a
it's a kind of a small effect um
and uh uh but you know what by the time
you're in space
um with no sort of uh
protection from the atmosphere cosmic
rays are more of a big deal and when you
get outside the van allen belts
um which are the um uh well actually
okay there's a different effect there
which has to do with um
uh
those are mostly electrons that i think
that come from uh solar flares
um and those are uh in
when we're in the protection of the
earth's atmosphere that's not such a big
deal when it's a question of um uh
things in space either satellites or
humans these solar flares i think
there's a famous one there was the
carrington event or something which was
a very big flare that just spewed
charged particles from the sun which
damaged all kinds of equipment um and
and can have an effect on the on the
earth's surface but but it's it's less
than much less than in space and those
things
for if you're an astronaut in space
that's a that's a much more significant
effect but i think it's not uh by the
way on on the surface of the earth
you know you live at a higher altitude
you get more radiation you live near the
poles
the um particularly the electrons from
the sun tend to spiral in near the
magnetic poles of the earth and they're
the things that lead to for example the
aurora borealis and things like that uh
the auroras those are the results of
electrons um hitting uh molecules of
things like oxygen in the upper
atmosphere of the earth and producing
light when they when they hit the upper
atmosphere but those are that's a sign
that there's a whole bunch of electrons
coming in um that represent radiation um
so there's more radiation near the
magnetic poles than there is in other
parts of the earth but these are not
significant effects and um uh i don't
think there's there's no evidence of of
that i'm aware of of um
uh of kind of um
sort of terrible effects from that i
mean people are very interested in in
radiation effects from all kinds of
things like one of the ones that's a a
big a big issue of of some controversy
is cell phones and um
the radiation that comes from the
microwave antennas of cell phones and
there's a lot that's done to try and
reduce the amount of microwave radiation
not the same thing as radiation of the
of the of ionizing radiation which comes
from radioactivity microwave radiation
is essentially just cooking you like it
does in a microwave oven it's not uh
it's not doing the things when you have
ionizing radiation it actually will
destroy molecules and things and destroy
pieces of dna and things like that um
it's a much more gradual process when
you're just sort of cooking them with
microwaves and so on but there's a lot
that's done with cell phones and so on
to try and prevent it being the case
that you get lots of radiation when you
like hold the cell phone up to your ear
and there's a whole elaborate scheme of
you know when you put your hand around
the cell phone it can sense that and it
reduces the power that it's transmitting
and so on and so on and so on um but
there's sort of a continuing question of
what biological effects can uh cell
phone radiation actually have and for
example 5g
cell phones which work in a different
way and have much more local uh
local um uh transmission is that
different i mean my own guess without
really knowing too much about it is that
uh 5g is a more
more directed kind of setup and there's
less kind of intense broadcast radiation
and my guess would be it will be a
a better situation in terms of of being
cooked by it um than than earlier
technologies but i'm not sure about that
um but i think the um this question is
what actually does it do what does a you
know a a few gigahertz
um uh uh piece of radiation from a cell
phone actually do to biological material
um one doesn't really know and you know
there's certainly concern that there are
protein molecules that are just the
right length to kind of be
be sort of
be be
flapped around so to speak by
by those microwaves and so on but but it
isn't really known um and and they're
at best kind of um
there's sort of
lots of studies that have been done and
lots of studies on different kinds of
animals and lots of studies that show
different kinds of effects and i think
it's all still still quite muddy um it's
probably one of these cases where
the uh
it's a it's a difficult case where kind
of um socio-political issues intersect
with scientific and medical issues and
it's kind of hard to know what's going
on
um but that that's um
but that's not radiation in the sense of
ionizing radiation that's radiation in
the sense of uh just uh microwaves of
the kind that you find cooking food in
the microwave oven and so on
um
let's see
uh
okay there was a question here
from
danielle if i were able to create a
black hole the size of a marble in my
living room
would it destroy the cosmos or just make
a hole in my couch
okay
so a black hole the size of a marble
let's see
uh
well one question is how massive is a
black hole the size of a marble
i think that the sun
uh
something a bit bigger than the sun that
turns into a black hole
there's this thing called the
schwarzschild radius which is the kind
of
the typical radius of the sort of
outside the event horizon of the black
hole and i'm trying to remember how big
that is it's on the order of kilometers
a kilometer or so i think for something
of the mass of the sun
so i think uh
for something the
size of a marble you're talking about
an object
that has the gravitational attraction
of um uh something pretty big you know a
planet-sized thing i suspect um and so
that means that you're kind of
concentrating all the gravity from that
really pretty big thing into that tiny
object and so yes the the you know
there'll be a gravitational attraction
of everything to that object
um and uh the um
and what will that do well it's it's
kind of like just um it's it's
it's just like it's like a it will be
kind of a bit like a magnet except that
it's a magnet that just doesn't doesn't
just apply itself
to materials that happen to be magnetic
but gravity has the feature that
anything with mass is attracted by
gravity and so that means that any
material actually anything anything with
uh
in some sense anything is attracted by
gravity um that's kind of the way that
general relativity in the the structure
of spacetime works um that sort of
anything is but one could think of is
anything is distorted to kind of fall
towards the this thing that is uh the
source of gravity and someone could
expect that unlike you know you if you
had a room that was all magnetic and you
had this very very strong magnet um
again a magnet actually works in
slightly different way because a magnet
always has a north and south pole
whereas gravity is just like everything
is being pulled into one place
um
it's uh
so it will be kind of like everything is
being attracted to this one place
and i'm uh you can be quite certain that
any any structure like um
um
well the question is would the earth be
sucked into a thing of the size of a
marble my guess is the answer to that is
yes
um but i think it's a slightly more
detailed question and how far
how far the effect how far out the
effect will be and what will tend to
happen is around a black hole you'll
eventually get
things will start swirling around
instead of just being some things that
don't have any angular momentum will
just be pulled
straight into the black hole but things
that do have some kind of swirling
motion will start being swirled around
and they'll swirl around faster and
faster and typically as they approach
the black hole they'll be swirling so
fast that they're emitting that they'll
start emitting light and they'll start
emitting x-rays and so on as they kind
of pulled faster and faster and faster
and um towards the black hole and
eventually they will go through the
event horizon of the black hole and be
lost forever so to speak um but yes so i
think i think um
kind of a bad um uh not
um not a safe thing to have in your
uh you know if you have a a pocket black
hole
um you don't get to have a pocket or a
planet i suspect for for very long
um
let's see
um
yeah this is the same i'm happy to talk
about
any kind of
a
science question
okay
it's a question from zayden is it true
that our electrical distribution
networks and neuronal networks in the
brain have the same configuration i
don't particularly think so
um i think that
there are
um
in the brain well
okay so the brain has
you know 100 billion neurons each one
connected to maybe a thousand other
neurons and they're you know millimeters
long and things like that they have
little wires effectively going out from
them that produce this very complicated
uh electrical connection network
um the the purpose of that electrical
connection network in some sense is to
have us be able to think
and so it's kind of like things you know
one neuron is activating other neurons
it's activating other neurons and in the
end we say hello or whatever
um the electrical distrib but these
neurons are sometimes organized and i
think there are cortical columns that
are a whole sort of organized structures
of neurons and so on and they're sort of
modular pieces of the brain i don't
think it's super well understood what
the you know how those modular pieces
what the significance of that is and all
those kinds of things
um when it comes to the electrical
distribution system
uh i'm
uh you tend to have setups where
um well okay there is one place that it
is a bit similar so
um
when you are sort of sending electricity
a long distance
you end up wanting to have it be at very
high voltage
and you put it in wires that are kind of
long distance wires and that's different
from what you get when you just plug
your computer into an outlet or
something um that's 240 volts whereas
the the um the wires that are used to to
transmit electricity over large
distances they're 20 000 volts usually
or more than that and there's sort of a
different
way of setting things up so that you're
kind of optimized for long distance
transmission and it's a little bit the
same for us
because the nerves that the nerve cells
are in our brain they're just sort of
sending signals you know electrical
signals one nerve cell next but in the
end we want to activate our muscles you
know in the finger fingers or something
and that requires that we send an
electrical signal from our brain all the
way down our arms to our fingers and so
they're actually different kinds of
nerves the the nerves in our brain don't
have myelin sheaths
the nerves that go long distances have
myelin sheaths and they're basically
associated with trying to keep the
signal kind of treat the electrical
signal kind of going for further and
that's a little bit analogous not not
exactly the same physics but a little
bit analogous to what's done in um
in the case of electrical transmission
systems where you're kind of having
something different about what's going
to be transmitted over a long distance
than the the very local stuff that's the
closest i would know to to um uh to how
that might work
um the question here from mikhail about
life on europa moon of jupiter
um
i am not super familiar with um
uh i'm afraid these these different
moons of jupiter are not all my personal
friends you know uh enceladus and moon
of saturn is another one people talk
about io i think people sometimes talk
about i mean europa is a is a moon that
i think has kind of oceans um that are
under its outer surface because things
are pretty cold out at jupiter most of
the time um the uh
mostly the light of the sun
is you know the sun is a pretty small
point of light in the sky by the time
you get out to jupiter but there are
still things that can heat things up
like for example the force of gravity on
the tidal forces um the essentially the
tides this
even in the earth there are solid tides
that are raised on the earth there are
tides in the ocean where you're pulling
water sort of closer that's close to the
moon gets pulled up higher and further
away from the moon gets sort of uh goes
goes further away that's a tidal
deformation of the earth associated with
the gravity of the moon in addition to
the water on the earth which is sort of
an easy soft target in some sense for
being pulled by the gravity by by
gravity like that
there is also a solid tide in the earth
where the rock of the earth is slightly
deformed by the moon so there are
similarly solid tides in these other
bodies
around jupiter and so on and i think
that there is a certain amount of
heating that happens as a result of the
those solid tides kind of squashing and
unsquashing parts of these um uh these
these moons and so on and i think the uh
people
talk about um the fact that things are
not so inhospitable in the ocean that's
uh kind of underneath the the outer
surface
of um of europa at least that's that's
my recollection of it and certainly
there are there are some very fun
project ideas about spacecraft that
would kind of uh drill through the outer
ice or something and go and and uh sort
of hang themselves down into that ocean
and see whether any critters uh swimming
around in there
but i'm not i'm not an expert in all of
the details of that
um i think the the whole question of you
know where is their life
uh you know depends what you mean by
life if you mean very earth-like life
well on earth
life does pretty well in many situations
you know it succeeds in being in
hydrothermal vents that are pretty hot
and pretty full of sulfur and so on in
the oceans
it succeeds in going a certain distance
to in antarctica although it doesn't
really quite make it in the coldest
places in antarctica it goes a certain
distance down in the rock of the earth
but doesn't go that far down you know if
you drill down a mile and under the
earth you won't find any life there if
you go into the atmosphere you know well
birds fly at a certain height and so on
but when you get up to the very upper
atmosphere there isn't any life there
either so you know there's a certain
zone in which life seems to thrive at
least life based on dna and proteins and
things like that
and so when we look for life that's like
that elsewhere in the solar system we
have to find environments that are
within the range of of temperature
particularly that and pressure actually
that um that can sustain the same kinds
of molecules and so on and so there are
limited number of places in the solar
system where that works
you know on venus for example there are
kind of maybe in the high clouds of
venus the surface is too hot um but
maybe in the clouds there can be sort of
things flapping around there that um or
floating around there um there were
plenty of um you know i think it's
quite easy for small things to be sort
of suspended in the upper upper
atmosphere there i think and there are
other particular places in the solar
system where it's sort of roughly within
the bounds of uh kind of the the
temperature and pressure and so on that
the molecules that make up life on earth
can thrive in um
let's see
uh
well a lot of more technical questions
here but i think this is probably not
the place for those
um
it's a question here about how do
batteries wear out
uh it's a slightly i know a little bit
about that
one of the funny things that happens in
batteries is that you form these
dendrites where where you've basically
formed sort of dendrites are like what
you get in snowflakes they're kind of a
form of crystallization where you're
just getting all this all this sort of
tree-like fluffy stuff formed and that's
something that happens in batteries and
i think gradually you're effectively
shorting out the battery as you form
these these little tendrils inside it i
think
um that's um and i think when you see
that kind of white fuzzy stuff that's
that's kind of what's happened there
but i'm not i'm not completely sure
about that
um
all right well we should probably uh
uh
soon wrap up for today here but um
let's see if there's maybe one other
thing
um
it's a comment from
uh
william
about 3d printing in space um
that
making the comment that i was saying on
on earth it's very important to have
supports it's like how do you build the
thing up and um how do you uh make uh
sort of things
go um
uh you know what do you you can't have a
thing that's just floating in the middle
of uh in in the air so to speak it has
to be supported uh otherwise it just
falls under gravity and so william was
commenting well would 3d printing be
easier in space
um that's an interesting comment and and
um uh the trouble with things in space
in microgravity you know in in if you're
in the space station or something
uh the whole point is it's like it's
like if you're on an elevator and
everything fails really can't happen in
in modern elevators but and the
elevators just drops under gravity and
it's just
falling then i suppose they're probably
rides at amusement parks that do this
where you're just falling
well then everything is weightless in
the sense that
there is there is no
it's not like if you hold out your hand
and there's a thing above your hand um
it won't fall towards your hand because
your hand and it are falling at exactly
the same rate and so it it appears to be
weightless to you because you're in kind
of a reference frame in which
that
everything is falling so to speak
and uh you know people do that with
planes
there is a parabolic trajectory that's
the trajectory that's the same
trajectory if you if you threw something
and it fell under gravity and it was
still going forward a bit it would cut
it would trace out a parabola more or
less up to air resistance issues
and planes if they fly on a parabolic
trajectory the people inside them can uh
feel weightless for a little while until
the plane has to pull up and not crash
into the ground um
and uh so that's you know you can you
can kind of simulate small amounts of
weightlessness okay what happens in in
space well in in if you're on the space
station the space station in orbit is
sort of continually falling towards the
earth except that it doesn't doesn't
crash into the earth because by the time
it's fallen that far it's over the side
of the earth it's just going to make an
orbit around the earth
um and so things are weightless usually
it's said to be microgravity because
there are small perturbations in the in
the the shape of the earth is not
precisely spherical and there are other
effects that cause there to be and
they're even the effect of gravity of
the actual pieces of the space station
have mass and produce some gravity but
it's you know it's very small gravity
so things are more or less weightless
and so then the question is well what
happens so let's imagine you had a
one of the things that's confusing is if
you pick something up
and
you are sort of floating
in the space station you throw something
well momentum conservation says if you
throw something in this direction and it
has some momentum in that direction
momentum has to be conserved so there
has to be some momentum going the
opposite direction it's newton's third
law to every action there's an equal and
opposite reaction and so you throw the
thing that way and you recoil back
and if you're a lot heavier than the
thing you threw well momentum is a mass
times velocity so you have less velocity
than the thing you threw if your mass is
larger but still you'll recoil a certain
amount
and and so that's the sort of confusing
thing about a lot of stuff that happens
in microgravity is that sort of uh
things just things just keep moving so
for example i would suspect that when
you extrude plastic
from a um uh that that whereas
in um
you're kind of uh you're squirting it
out
and on
in gravity on earth the the little
stream that you're squirting out will
sort of fall down it'll it'll make a
kind of pool and it'll solidify but in
space the thing you're squirting out
won't fall anywhere it'll just keep
squirting out
and and so i suspect there are a bunch
of really complicated issues about
dealing with
uh
doing 3d printing in space and i i have
heard of 3d printing being done in space
i'm not sure exactly how it'll work but
for example when you have a water of
some water
you um you know on earth you can make a
water drop but the water drop will be
you know will be deformed by gravity and
will fall and will just go splat but in
space you can make a big blob of water
in fact one of the issues in space
stations and so on is that you know
gradually people spill water and things
like that and what happens to water it
doesn't just go in a drain and fall down
it just makes a big blob somewhere and
so i think this was a problem
particularly with the mers space station
back in the day that there were just big
blobs of water everywhere and what do
you what do you do you have to sort of
vacuum up these big blobs of water and
it's kind of rather rather icky to do
the whole thing
but um you know so so you have a big
in microgravity you have a big blob of
water and you can do things like you can
blow on one side of it and the water
will will move around because the water
tends to tends to make a sphere because
of surface tension so it will tend to be
the case that the the layer of atoms
right on the surface uh will be that the
atoms in the interior will be pulling
the atoms on the surface and so what
will tend to happen is that the thing
will have the minimum surface area
because the atoms in the interior are
pulling on the atoms on the surface and
there's nothing to pull outwards on the
atoms on the surface and so the thing
will form into the the shape that has
the minimum surface area which if there
are no other constraints is a sphere but
then you can like glow on one side of
the sphere and it'll kind of wobble
around and maybe the thing will start
rotating and if you start it rotating it
will eventually as as you rotate it it
will get elongated um just as the earth
gets elongated actually although it's a
solid object and you know the elongation
is quite small at the equator but but a
drop of of water in space will get
elongated quite easily as you as you
kind of spin it around
and actually one thing i was curious
about for a long time
is what happens to a splash in space
so uh when you kind of drop water on
on a solid surface or you drop water
into water they look a bit different
what happens is the you can get it's one
of the early applications for flash
photography was taking these pictures of
uh kind of at the moment of impact what
does it actually look like and what it
looks like is there's this kind of crown
shape that forms the corona it's called
and the the the drop comes in and then
there's this kind of uh sheath of water
that goes out and then as the sheath of
water as this kind of cylinder of water
goes out it breaks up into a bunch of
spikes that look like kind of the the um
the spikes of a crown
and and that's the typical form of a
splash and then it forms into that and
then the wall of water crashes and
there's falls down into gravity right in
the center
there will be for example if you drop a
drop of water into water there will
actually be the drop drops in and
there'll actually be a sort of rebound
drop where the thing forms a kind of
stem and then there'll be a little drop
at the top of that stem and it's like
you drop the water in and right where it
fell in there will be this kind of this
tower that develops which eventually
will end up with a drop at the end so
these two effects there's this one sort
of corona that forms from the outer part
of the splash and this thing in the
center what happens in the outer part of
the splash is this
if if you have a sheet of water it's
unstable because of surface tension
because this what happens is you have
the sheet of water and it will tend to
be the case that if the sheet has one
little tiny imperfection in it it will
tear apart because the water really
wants to be clumped together more it
doesn't want to be spread out in the
sheet the surface tension will tend to
clump it together that way and so that's
a a type of instability that happens in
kind of sheets of water and so on um and
um
so that's what's going on in splash so
the question is what happens in a splash
in space and so years ago now i i knew
some astronauts and i said can't you
just try this
and they said we really don't want to
try this because if you make a splash
you know if you take some water and you
go you know you hit it against some
surface or whatever it'll shatter and
all the little pieces of water all the
water drops will go all over the place
and we'll be cleaning up water drops for
for months afterwards so to speak so not
a good experiment to try
but so i i still don't really know what
happens with splashes in space i think i
think somebody did actually eventually
try something like that
and i i mean my guess about what would
happen
well i'm actually not sure i think the
instability the surface tension
instability will be there but whether
you would see
kind of uh sort of rivers of of whether
what you would see is something which is
more like a um uh you know the water
drop hits something and more like uh
kind of this this tube of of water comes
back reflected so it's as if it might be
um you know a billiard ball hitting
something and the whole billiard ball is
reflected um i i kind of have the
suspicion that it's more like a tube of
water that gets reflected back but i
don't know for sure um but uh um
it's um
um
it's a uh
yeah it's a
maybe somebody has tried that experiment
by now
um
uh
they said comments that um isn't it that
weird that our body mostly works fine in
zero gravity yeah it is kind of weird it
is kind of weird i mean a lot of aspects
of the way we work
are based on uh kind of you know there
are a lot of things that kind of
um
are
one would think were things sort of
falling and pooling but i think the
basic point is
that
you know there's our blood pressure
for example is comparatively high
it is not you know there's actually a
pressure that our heart is putting to
pump blood through our system and that's
sufficiently high
that it sort of overcomes the basic
force of gravity and i suppose in i
don't really know whether in sort of it
was an evolutionary thing to oh you can
eat when you're hanging upside down in a
tree type thing and that will probably
force certain things to work even when
the gravity is the wrong way round but
yeah one would think and i know it
happens that there's a certain amount of
pooling of fluids and things like that
that happens in space and there's plenty
of things like uh you know bone mass
muscle mass things like that there's you
know it's when we get exercise on earth
we are resisting the force of a lot of
what we end up doing just walking around
and so on we are expending energy to
resist the force of gravity and we're
putting we're putting pressure on bones
and things like that
and we're we're sort of reminding the
bone you should be growing here i mean
it's it's the way that um uh
you know bones i think in um uh you know
for kids and so on there are growth
plates at the end of long bones like in
the in the legs and so on where there
are you know the the bones just grow at
those growth plates and depending on
sort of how much force is on that
they'll grow differently and that's why
for example there are complicated things
if the if you're if your gate is sort of
off and you are putting more pressure on
one side than the other then that will
have sort of so that can have nasty
feedback effects as that one grows more
than the other one grows and and so on
but yeah it is it is an interesting fact
that our bodies more or less work in
zero gravity you know the question is
um sort of will they work for the trip
to mars will they work you know what
will it be like if you hang out on mars
for uh you know for for 10 years
i mean people used to think when when
when cars
were just being invented people said you
know the human body is not going to
survive traveling at more than 20 miles
an hour or some such other thing now of
course as is often the case that sounds
like a kind of stupid statement but um
i think really roads were pretty bad
because they were really intended for
horses to you know to walk along and big
cartwheels and things to to go along and
you know people would imagine oh gosh if
you are going over those those um uh
those bumps at 50 miles an hour you know
you would just get to vibrate into
pieces um but of course then uh you know
roads got to be made smoother and things
like that and so the bumps disappeared
but not because of something you know
because of a difference in the way the
thing was set up i mean of course we
humans have all kinds of nasty
resonances because it's like uh you know
if you if you different frequencies
different parts of our insides will
start wobbling back and forth and uh can
cause all kinds of trouble but that
doesn't tend to be a thing that um
that happens because we're not typically
exposed to those frequencies um and uh
so so not not so much of an issue
all right well i see
some more questions here which would be
fun to answer a different time
and um
uh
i'm um
i think we should wrap up for now here
so
thanks for joining us and see you again
another week